will tell us about commitments to
Quantum States
until 12 15.
yeah how much time
25 minutes
all right hi everyone my name is Fermi
and I'm excited to tell you about
equipment's Quantum States this is Joint
work with Sam Nathan and Mark
okay so the motivating question for this
work is a very simple question is it
possible to commit to Quantum
information yes
thank you
[Laughter]
sorry
it's like this clicker isn't uh
all right I guess I'll use this
all right so what I mean zika
um
is uh the simple setting imaginable I
have a sender and a receiver Sander is
uh just thinking about some Quantum
state I'm going to write it as a pure
State throughout today but really this
can be an arbitrary Quantum state it can
be maybe entangled with something else
that you hold on to
um and all she wants to do is is place
the state in the equivalent of a digital
locked box and send it over to the
receiver
and later she should have the option to
open this commitment in such a way that
the receiver
can verify this opening and then open
this lock box and recover the the
originally committed message
so you may want some security properties
to go along with this and two typical
ones are hiding and binding and so
hiding would say that the commitment
should hide the underlying message the
quantum state from the receiver
and binding should say that the sender
can only open to a unique message right
that once you once you commit you can't
really change your mind to something
else
um and uh
um as the as stated here it seems like
there's a pretty easy answer to this
question there's actually a very simple
sort of folklore scheme
um actually if you were at svika's talk
this morning this was actually on one of
the slides implicitly
um where basically you you combine
something called the quantum one-time
pad with any commitment scheme that
allows you to commit to classical
messages so this latter can be
classically or quantumly instantiated
and so here's how it works let's say
you're committing to a one qubit message
for Simplicity
um you sample the sender will sample two
random classical bits A and B and it'll
send a commitment to these two classical
bits that's going to be this Capital C
and along with that it sends this
one-time padded version of the state PSI
so X here is the poly bit flip operator
at Maps zero to one one to zero uh Z is
going to be the phase slip operator so
it does nothing to zero like entity and
zero and on one it'll give a minus one
phase
and the fact we need to know here is
that if you take any arbitrary Quantum
State and you apply random X and Z's to
it you get something called the
maximally mixed States this is a density
Matrix that's independent of whatever
state you started out with
so that's going to be the commitment is
just this this one-time padded State
together with the commitment to the
underlying Keys A and B
um and later you you decommit to A and B
right and so the receiver will verify
this in the natural way it just checks
the classical commitment or the
commitment to a b
and then it can additionally just
recover the original message it can just
undo the pad right so it can apply Z to
the b x to the a to this one time padded
State and recover PSI
um so functionality I think is uh pretty
pretty straightforward and security also
seems pretty obvious
um so for hiding I'm not gonna formally
write anything out but the intuition I
think is uh be clear
um you know you you have a two parts to
your commitment one part is this
maximally mixed looking State and the
other part you know maybe that maybe
that causes trouble because it has
information about a b
um but we know that the underlying
commitment should be hiding
okay so it seems like a pretty easy
hybrid argument
uh for binding we want to say the sender
can only open to unique states PSI it
can't change the state after the
commitment
um and for this well I mean the the
receiver is holding on to x to the AZ to
the B side so it holds on to that
Quantum part and the only thing the
sender gets to do when it opens the
commitment is it can possibly change a
and b but that's precisely what the the
commitment to a b prevents you from
doing
so it seems uh like everything is just
fine
um there's one one issue
uh which is that it's totally unclear
what this actually means like what what
do we
like mean mathematically when we say
that a sender can only open to a unique
state
um and in fact if you were to yeah
um you said that PSI could be entangled
with something that that the sender
controls yeah couldn't the sender then
like measure the other part oh and break
security of this is yeah of binding um I
don't want to get into it but it turns
out you can't like you can as long as
the this
um the underlying fitment team is like
post Quantum secure uh you can't do
things like that
I think the point is that if you measure
it says State the sort of the joint
state of of his his own registers and
the committed State changes
um
X and commits to X like one of those X's
is
I mean in some sense it's like all along
you were just committing to the
distribution of zero at all right
um
so by the way can't I just say that
there's an unbounded procedure using
which the receiver can recover PSI and
that is the only side which the sender
can open to
um you could say that uh it wouldn't
satisfy this property though
um for instance if it's not
statistically binding
um like the the committed State could be
Independence of the receivers View yeah
but let's use uh statistically binding
commitment c yeah you can do that for
specifically binding
um you can do something like that
um but let's let's aim for let's aim for
a definition that doesn't uh
just work in that case
um okay so just to sum up
um our current understanding of fitments
to Quantum States is we have this one
clean folklore Construction
uh no security definitions
uh that's basically it
nothing yeah
okay but for me just to make the
previous point the right I mean if it's
statistically binding then yeah it's
fine then there are you can make
definitions and you can prove things but
nobody had done it but I think you can
do it uh nobody had written down even
like a statistical binding definition
for committing the quantum States
um it's not so hard to like think of one
like those people are doing right now
but uh
um uh you will get very very stuck in
just statistical land yeah but the point
the point is that you want something
that's more General right there should
be something that's more General yeah
yes
but ideally you want a definition of
binding that's like not like that's
agnostic to the the attack model right
you want some game where like if you
just make the adversary unbounded then
you have statistical binding right you
shouldn't have a definition that like
only works in one right
um it's typically what we want like
everywhere else in crypto
um
okay so
uh the goal of this work is really to
try to start building this theory of a
Quantum State commitment so uh
contributions are in three parts uh new
definitions uh constructions and
applications and they all kind of go
kick other
um so in the definition side or main uh
contribution is a is a simple like
game-based definition of binding
um in one line it says that when you
commit to a state side
um that the safe side should be your
computationally or statistically erased
from the sender's view after you commit
so I'll say a lot more about what that
actually means so if it's confusing
don't worry just yet
um this definition has a bunch of nice
properties it handles like commitments
to arbitrary entangled messages that's
going to be crucial for all the
applications
um it's justifiable uh composable and
parallel and sequence
um it can be seen as a generalization of
the higher definitions for for
commitments to classical messages
um and it has this uh cool property we
call this hiding binding Duality and
I'll get into that in a little bit too
on the construction side we've already
seen the construction of a hiding and
binding commitment to Quantum States and
indeed like you can show this that
really satisfies this definition
um
and uh we also give a brand new
construction we give the very first uh
succinct commitment to Quantum States so
this allows you to take a long Quantum
State like n qubits and send a much
smaller number of qubits to commit to
this uh to to commit to this longer
state
okay and both of these are uh going to
be completely non-interactive schemes I
could have been just one message the
opening is one message and they rely on
these weaker than one-way function
assumptions like both of them are from
assumptions that have been uh Black Box
separated from only functions
um although the The Hiding binding QSC
is from is from potentially weaker
assumption than the succinct one
so on the application side uh we have a
bunch of applications in the paper uh
really the flagship application though
um is uh this use of succinct Quantum
State commitments to get a quantum
analog of uh classical Suzuki arguments
so
um we have is this protocol that is
basically a Quantum generalization of
Killian's classical protocol where you
can take any Quantum PCP so I'm just
taking Quantum PCP to mean some long
Quantum States long Quantum proof that
you can check by just looking at a few
qubits
and you can take any Quantum PCP and
compile it together with any succinct
Quantum State commitment and you get a
quantum communication succinct argument
system
and so one thing this buys you is a
protocol for much weaker assumptions
when you know how to do classically so
we get a if you instantiate the quantum
PCP with a classical PCP you get a three
message synced argument for all NP from
these weaker than only function
assumptions in comparison killing
protocol takes one more message and uses
crhfs
um
have you done from three with stronger
assumptions
there's no kind of hat there's it's just
really one message yeah
classical very far uh Quantum it has to
perceive quite qubits and it has to
um everyone is going to be Quantum in
this world
um another thing you can do with Quantum
pcps is hope that they're uh more
powerful than classical pcps and indeed
this Quantum PCP conjecture pans out and
we would have Quantum pcps for all of
qma and uh in that we're all this this
uh this protocol would allow a richer
set of languages than than classical
synced arguments
arguments earlier and now the difference
is that your protocol also is quantum
yeah I see and if the protocol is
quantum then for their constructions
known earlier or so there was a
um the protocol that we analyze is like
very similar to uh sort of Oracle model
protocol that Lee judge and Ramy Mobile
stock have proposed about a year earlier
and actually this project kind of
started from looking at their paper and
thinking about what it meant
what is the notable this project
I am not the right person to ask
um
all that matters here is that like
Quantum pcts like what languages we have
Quantum PCP is for well at least NP
because I'm defining them to encapsulate
possible pcps and uh maybe it goes all
the way up to qma don't really know
is it possible to have like a commitment
to a Quantum state that is
computationally hiding in
computationally binding I mean but the
information has to be somewhere right I
mean I
uh sorry like what do you mean like uh
that is statistically binding it's also
computationally binding yeah no no I
mean that it's not it's not
statistically hiding it it's not
statistically buying that's what I mean
right I'm pretty sure I'm pretty sure
you can have something you can I think
you can have something where maybe like
the X information is on one side and the
Z informations on the other side
foreign
yeah and so for the applications this
turns out to be like the most technical
part of the work in the hospital the
part of the paper that I'll get into the
lease today
um but achieving all these results
requires a bunch of new tools for
um uh rewinding Quantum protocols and
showing how like how to extract Quantum
States
so it's a rough plan for the next half
hour
um we're just going to go into this
definition and explore this question of
what does it actually mean to commit to
a Quantum state
uh once we establish a definition I'll
talk about how to uh succinctly commit
to Quantum States and then I'll briefly
discuss what goes into uh getting
Quantum succinct arguments
all right so actually before I go into
this question I just want to establish
some basic syntax that I'm going to use
for the rest of the stock
so we'll assume that the way that that
the sender and receiver
um commit to Quantum States is by just
applying some uh fixed like public
unitary or like fixed for every security
parameter
um so everybody knows the description of
this unitary com and to commit the
sender is just going to apply this
unitary to the message it wants to
commit to psi together with uh Lambda
zeros
and what it's going to do is it's going
to divide up the resulting stage into
two parts the C part sending for the
equipment and the d-part sending for the
the decommit manager opening
and so uh you still sometimes to just
call this this uh this joint State com
PSI
and so that's a state on C and D
and so you just send the C to commit and
then to decommit you just send the rest
of the stage
so when you when you commit you're
sending a state that's going to be
financially entangled with the state
that you're going to send when you when
you open
and the receiver to verify is going to
do the natural thing where it'll just
collect these two parts together and
then undo the commitment unitary
and then to check that the registers
that are supposed to be zero or actually
zero and if that track passes then it's
going to recover the committed state
from the remaining registers
also classical strings in addition so I
will just treat classical as some
Quantum so yeah yeah it can fit into
this this framework
um and one more thing I'll add is that
uh sort of any Quantum State commitment
can be
can be Rewritten in this form so if you
have a more General scheme with like
rounds of interaction back and forth
um there's a very fairly like Elementary
Quantum transformation that's basically
to like purify all the randomness or all
of the interaction and kind of compress
it into a single unitary and then it's
kind of based on some some prior work by
Virginia
uh the setting of committing the
classical bits
publicly known yes yeah
so both assignments you have to know it
to run their size of the protocol
um and that's all you write down to
specify the statement like there's
nothing else I use to specify the
construction other than this community
no it's a fixed it's a fixed unitary for
every Atlanta it's probably a security
founder it fixed in public description
like any Randomness that you need during
the protocol will be generated from the
quantum list like it will use those
those zeros to generate some randomized
okay so
um
now for for this question uh what does
it actually mean to commit to a Quantum
mistakes and um to kind of highlight the
the challenges that that go into
answering this question I just want to
recall the classical binding definition
um that we uh
um
so so this definition says that um a
classical equipment's name is binding uh
if the adversary can't out if an
adversary can't output a commitment seat
together with two ballot openings to two
different messages so m0 and M1 uh
there's r0 and I wanted to note the
additional opening information
foreign
a bunch of things go wrong when you try
to take this this basic definitional
template and extend it to our setting
where you're trying to commit to Quantum
States
so let me just outline a few of the the
issues
um so one issue is that in this
definition the Challenger needs to
verify but the two openings are actually
valid right it's a check that m0 r0 is a
valuable thing to see and it goes and
checks that m1r1 is about opening to see
as well
and uh in the quantum setting when the
commitments and the openings and
everything are potentially Quantum
um this weird thing happens or maybe the
order in which you check these two
openings matters like what if the first
when you check the first one you like
ruin the commitments and then now you
can't check the second one
um so already you're running into issues
like right away
um or maybe the more Quantum phrasing of
this is that the verification of the two
uh openings might not commute
um also when you have these Quantum
messages uh there's other chat that we
are never think about in the classical
setting it's totally trivial just
verifying these two strings are
different uh if those are two arbitrary
Quantum States if the Challenger doesn't
know in advance then I there's no like
physical procedure uh even to verify
that two Quantum stage are different
what does that even mean
um and finally uh
certainly have to break binding in this
way right it doesn't have to if I can if
it can change his mind about what it
opens to that doesn't necessarily mean
that it can open to two different things
at the same time like perhaps you know
it can open to either m0 or M1 but the
way it opens that I'm one is by
destroying its opening to m0 and so this
problem had actually been observed even
in the the post Quantum setting uh by
several works
um but kind of if you take all three of
these things together
um you know it's not totally obvious at
priori that that a good cryptography
definition is possible when you're in
the setting of of just committing to
information sort of from a continuous
space
okay so um you know as a result of all
this stuff uh our new definition is
going to look a little bit different
from this classical binding definition
so here it is it's uh we call it swap
binding and here's a security game so
it's an interactive game between an
adversary and a challenger and the
adversary is first going to send a
commitment together with its opening fee
to the Challenger the Challenger just
goes ahead and verifies that CMD is
valid and if it's invalid just stops
there it's not going to continue
um uh at the commence valid then it's
going to sample a random b
if the bid is one it's going to do
nothing it's going to leave everything
alone
and if it is zero it's going to replace
the underlying committed message with a
jump message so what I mean by that is
is when I say swap side with junk what I
mean is well first you have to you know
undo the commitment to reveal the
message
and then I'm going to run the swap
circuit which will just replace the PSI
with with the whatever other state I
feed into it so in this case I'm just
feeding the junk zero States
so I've replaced that message with zero
and then I'll recommit and then I send
back this this opening D back to the
adversary so the adversary's job in this
game is to detect whether it got back
its original opening
or an opening to just a junk unrelated
message
and we say it's binding if and only if
uh it's hard to win this game this
distinguishing game uh with better than
one half probability
so maybe a little bit more uh compactly
and informally what we're really saying
is that uh commitments to psi should be
indistinguishable from any side of the
adversary picks it could be
indistinguishable from commitments to
zero uh if you only get to see the D
part of the commitment okay so
throughout this uh we should think of
the adversaries only getting to see the
D part because we're thinking about like
you've sent the commitment away right
the only part you have left is the
opening
one question so why do you need to swap
the
stay with the Champions they produce a
new uh yeah yeah you're totally right
you could at least with this syntax
that's totally a problem I think in
maybe a few more general settings this
definition General is a little more a
little better than that but for
certainly with on the slide you could
imagine an alternative game where it's
not a swap but I just give you back the
a difference
right so wait I am a little bit confused
so how does the state be which you are
sending depend upon your bit fee oh so
so if uh if the bid is one then I
descend back so just assume the sender
sends a valid sentence opening and then
if the bill is one I always return the
same D that is happening
and at a bit of zero I will send it back
to the commitment to an unrelated
message
so it has to tell like whether it held
on whether I just gave it back the same
thing or whether I just gave it back
some totally unrelated opening to a
different message
so so I think this definition is like on
the face of it a very weird way to
define binding right we typically think
of binding as a search problem right
where uh you try to find some way to to
open the equipment in different ways
um and for some reason we've written
down a distinguishing game here and said
that binding is equivalent to succeeding
in this in this like distinguishability
path and so that I think requires a bit
of uh justification
yeah should it should it be clear that
this definition implies the formal
definition or no okay
so um the
uh
the principle of the part of this
definition is a thing called the
swapping distinguishing equivalence
which is a sort of folklore in Cloud
information but only like recently
formally written down in this work of
Aaron sanatia and Sasuke and it says
that
um the following tasks are equivalent
for a pair of orthogonal period States X
and Y
um an equivalent of a very strong sense
like if you can do one with like some
Epsilon Advantage you can also do the
other one uh it's like Epsilon squared
Advantage
um and uh basically like the the
circuits you would use for either one or
more or less the same with a few like
semantic changes
um and the two tasks are swapping
between the the pair of States so the
task is like given one of the states
output the other state y or Y to X
um and this distinguishing Casper either
randomly given X Plus y or x minus y and
you have to tell which one is which
and uh
um there's sort of a proof by picture of
this
um where if you were to draw out like
what these States look like you X and Y
at 90 degrees and then you draw where X
Plus Y is it and then the middle of 45
degrees x minus y
um uh just to get some intuition like
think about you know how you would show
that a distinguisher gives you a way to
swap between these states so like what
would it mean to distinguish between X
Plus y and x minus y
um well you might want to have a
projector a production that can
distinguish between these two and
um like where would this projector be
well claim that a useless distinguisher
would be one that's like right in the
middle of the two states
if this pie this we're right in the
middle of X Plus One X minus y it would
not be able to distinguish between the
two they would have the equal weights of
like measuring onto onto this Pi desk or
something so using it it's uh equivalent
to test one distinguish between the plus
and minus and the other is
distinguishing between whether you
swapped or you didn't swap no
um the worst off is a little bit
overloaded here but what I mean is that
change from one state to the other so I
give you the X States and you win if you
can give me the y space
they're concerned about like states that
are very hard to describe and they want
to talk about like the concrete like
circuit complexity of like implementing
these tasks
um uh so that's not quite the crypto
setting but it's just the easiest one to
sort of describe this principle
um so uh you know if you have a
distinguisher for these two states X
Plus One X minus y the claim is that the
distinguisher has to sort of be a little
bit far away from X right if the
distinguisher were exactly parallel to X
that would be like a useless
distinguisher like perfectly can't
distinguish X Plus y and x minus y
EP but the moment you have this the
ability to to implement a distinguisher
that's a little bit a little bit away
from X that actually gives you a a way
to swap between the states X and Y it's
very proportional Advantage so one way
you could do it for instance is just
measure that that Pi dist and then once
you've got a state once you start with X
then measuring this pie this gives you a
state with some small component on a y
and you can show this is like roughly
proportional to the original
distinguishing advantage and this really
goes in both directions too that if you
have a way to swap you can show it's
really a reflection about a particular
Subspace and like that Subspace gives
you a distinguishing measurement
okay so it's something that you can
really like prove by destroying this
picture in a sheet of paper and really
convincing yourself the tasks for the
same thing
let me try to translate that to the
setting of commitments
um
so uh and this is just to build
intuition so let's just suppose a sender
honestly commits to a classical bit so
either zero or one
and so then we're looking at these
computational tasks that involve a
particular pair of of care States right
so either this commitment to zero or
this commitment to one state these are
these bipartite states and on C and D
and one thing we definitely want our
equipment to satisfy so the sender
cannot swap between these two states
that that if uh if the sender initially
commits to zero and then gives away the
C part of the state then by acting only
on the the D commitment part it can't
swap between commitment to Zero moves to
one right that would be totally breaking
the commitment binding security
um and through this uh through this
equivalence it turns out that you can
just write down this uh the Dual version
of this test right this uh what we want
is that if we want to say that you can't
swap between this pair of States uh we
can equivalently require that you cannot
distinguish between the sum and their
difference
and the sum of these two states is the
commitment to the plus state so zero
plus one and the difference is the
commitment to the minus state zero minus
one
and uh it turns out that this is
essentially like unru's collapse binding
definition so what uh you know as a
paper defining this notion of what it
means we bind it in classical bits and
secure against Quantum attacks
um and uh the definition is something
about uh your inability to detect the
measurement and the Fairly Elementary
Quantum manipulations you can show it's
basically this this requirement that you
can't distinguish between commitments to
plus and commitments to minus
um so what we care about is you know the
setting where the sender May commit to
arbitrary States PSI uh so just keeping
things simple let's suppose the center
honestly commits to some arbitrary pure
State site
Sandra can't swap between commitments to
psi and commitments to some orthogonal
State Side
okay
um and so the equivalent the the Dual
version of this task is is or the Dual
requirement is that we'd say well they
shouldn't be able to distinguish between
commitment to psi plus hyper and PSI
minus hyper given only the D part
and this is precisely what swap binding
is going to guarantee us that guarantees
like for anything that you commit to
it's uh given just a D part you can't
distinguish
um uh that from the commitment to zero
so just one hybrid switch would give you
uh this indistinguishability we want
here
because both the left and right sides
are indistinguishable room commitments
to zero given just the B part
so
um
you know maybe that was a bit fast but
really like what we're doing with the
swapping distinguishing Duality is we're
taking this this thing we want to
enforce which is that the sender should
not be able to equivocate between
equipment to science and cyberp but
we're the Challenger we don't know what
Psy is in the first place like we have
no clue with the sender is arbitrarily
picking this side so we don't really
know like when it's it's changed from
side to side perf it doesn't feel like a
a a task that we can like efficiently or
we can efficiently test if the adversary
has actually done it and what this
Duality lets you do is it turns it into
something that is very easily testable
right I can uh I can have the adversary
give me like
um
uh uh give me these states and then just
play this distinguishing game where
they're asked to decide whether or not I
gave back their original states or their
original decommitment or an unrelated
one and so that's really the role that
this is playing but this like this basic
Quantum principle lets you uh take a
task where it's not clear how you would
test it and turn it into like a simple
distinguishing game and that's why
that's why it's uh possible to write
down a cryptographic definition here
um so I've only talked about honest
Enders here but you know in the paper we
really show that this swap binding
definition captures security against
arbitrary malicious sending sender
strategies
can you show that these are some sense
which things are more legal one
um like is it true that uh
[Music]
yes
okay so a few additional properties of
definition sort of mentioned already
um it doesn't really care about whether
you're committing to Pure States or
parts of some larger entangled State and
this is actually necessary for all the
applications
um and it's sort of incredibly
composable you can instantiate this in
the statistical or computational
settings
um and this allows you to formalize that
folklore construction from earlier
so one other nice feature
um it's kind of surprising to us at
least is that this definition is the
swap by any notion is is dual to hiding
the very precise sense
um maybe this was clear from the
equivalents already but uh and saw
binding is saying that the D part of the
of the overall like CD State hide the
underlying committed message
and this whole time I kind of slept
hiding under the rug I didn't even
Define it but if you wanted to Define
hiding the natural definition to write
down or a natural definition would be
the same one on the slide except where
the Challenger sends the C register back
to the to the center or to the to the
receiver in this case
um so hiding says that the commitment
part the C part hides the underlying
station
okay and so you get this uh a nice way
to sort of switch between your hiding
and binding guarantees where um if you
have a scheme where C is the equipment
and D is the opening you could imagine a
dual scheme where you send the opening
as the commitment and the commitment
does the opening and this uh uh like
immediately swaps the the computational
statistical properties of hiding and
binding so if you had a like
statistically binding scheme originally
you would get a statistically hiding
scheme after you swap the rolls of
equipment in the opening so lives be
binding at all
if you just send A and B it doesn't
bind you to the message yeah yeah so so
it has to do with this like
a really good question um it has to do
with this uh like General syntax that
I've assumed for that scheme is actually
not written in that syntax there's like
this choice of Randomness and if you
were to purify that Randomness you would
get something where D is actually
defining
if you were to get rid of all the
classical Randomness and write it as a
single unitary then you would actually
uh get the date
okay so yeah
previous slide says that there are two
different schemes one of which gives you
hiding one of which gives you binding
and we want to say that there's a single
scheme that gives you both oh no yeah so
if you start with a scheme that is both
hiding and binding then the hiding says
that c hides a message and the bindings
are the D hyper message and so if you
were to sort of switch the roles of c
and d you would still have the same
thing both sides are individually on
their own hiding the message
um but if you had like a statistical
guarantee on one side and a
computational the other you would have
switched them when you switched the
rules at CMP okay you're totally right
you want it on the boat you don't want
it on it's just one unless you have some
other property
um right so what I want to talk about
next is how to succinctly commit to
Quantum States
um and so what I mean by this is that I
want to commit to an end qubit Quantum
state with a commitment that's much
shorter so smaller than any qubits and I
just want this binding property I'm
actually going to forget about hiding I
won't actually need it for my
applications
um and with this Duality uh we can sort
of reframe the problem uh I mean the
Dual scheme would be one where the
opening is uh is smaller than n qubits
and instead of binding you have hiding
now
and uh at least for me like this is a
little bit easier to think about
um like I think it's uh maybe more
natural to think about like how do you
hide information we have many ways to do
that
um because really the Dual scheme is
just a rephrasing of like it's asking
for an encryption scheme right it's
asking for a way to encrypt and uncue
the message
um with a corresponding like opening
register that is shorter than the
message and it turns out that you can do
this when whenever you have an
encryption scheme where the keys uh an
encryption scheme for Quantum states
where the keys are shorter than the
state itself
and it's just one times a year
so just a concrete example
um so you can Quantum one time pad and N
Cube at state with a pseudo-random
string and that'll work so here's how
this uh
example construction
um you could have a pseudo random
generator that stretches an N over two
bit seed to a two end bit output
and repair superposition over all seeds
for this prg and then control then
that's seed K you apply a pseudo-random
poly pad the X to the first half of the
prg output Z to the second half of the
prg output you apply that to This n Cube
it states PSI
okay so you've kind of like encrypted
your your uh your estate in
superposition and then you do this
curious thing where you send away the
keys as the commitment
right it's a very weird thing to do to
like encrypt your own message and then
send the keys to the receiver
um but that's what binding says is the
right that's what our binding definition
says you should be doing but that
binding security comes when and the part
that you hold on to is a sender hides
your original message
so here if I if I send away the keys
then from my point of view if I only
hold on to the deregister it looks like
K Is Random
and once a seed for the prg is random
then I can invoke prg security to say
that it looks like there's a
that's the D register is just a
maximally mixed state this is like a
true Quantum One Time Pad
um
a few confused Expressions so maybe uh
it still doesn't work
so doesn't work classically it really
doesn't work possibly yeah you really
like shouldn't uh do this yes it's like
the the magic of entanglement here is
really is doing all the work
so um yeah because the the seed to the
prg is short this is assisting
commitment
yes and um
uh in fact you don't even need one-way
functions
um so keeping in the theme with the
workshop uh in the paper we show that
like this kind of encryption can be
built from actually any so-called
pseudorandom unitary
um and by uh work of William frutchmer
um there's this is like quantumly Oracle
separated from one-way functions it's a
potentially weaker assumption
um
so
these are synced Quantum stake fitments
in many ways behave like a Quantum
analog of collision resistant hash
functions so they they readily compose
you can take uh the moment you get one
qubit of compression you can compose
that and get any amount of compression
uh and uh you can even do Merkle trees
so you can do a succinct commitment to a
long Quantum stage and give short like
local openings to like to to individual
qubits
and so this uh just looks exactly like a
classical Merkle tree exceptions we've
replaced every uh
um every invocation of the hash function
with a succinct Quantum commitment so
you can start out with a long Quantum
stage break it up into small pieces and
then just tree hashes stuff with these
succinct Quantum commitments
um and so so classically right these
sort of tree commitments are the key
cryptographic components of distinct
Arguments for for NP so
um so succinct argument is a very very
efficient protocol a very efficient
interactive protocol was an approver and
a verifier
um where the total communication and
verification efficiencies is very very
good it's much better than just
extending an NP Witness
and the argument part just means that uh
we only ask for soundness against
computers
um and in Killian's protocol in one line
uh the idea is you do a tree commitment
to a locally checkable proof
so or a PCP and then after that you do a
PCP verification
okay so uh
I said earlier we give a Quantum analog
of this protocol so we show that with
these Quantum three commitments plus any
Quantum PCP you get a quantum succinct
argument protocol
um
and uh it looks just like Killian's
protocol so the prover will start out
with it's Quantum PCP it uh tree hatches
it up using these distinct Quantum
statements and gets a short route of a
few a few qubits sends that over
and then the verify will run a PCP check
so it'll ask to see a few positions of
this Quantum proof the prover has to
reveal those corresponding positions so
it does uh you know open these like uh
route to leaf paths
and this allows the verifier to uh to
well the verifier will check whether the
opening is valid and then reveal the
proof at those positions and run the PCP
check
so maybe I'll skip the concrete
corollaries
um and just jump straight to soundness
so uh the difficult part of this is not
like writing down the protocol but
thinking about how you actually uh prove
that these Protocols are sound right
under uh under the assumption that you
have as a sync to QSC
so even in the classical setting even
when the protocol is entirely classical
uh this is not so straightforward so let
me just spend one slide kind of
recapping what you do in the classical
setting
um so the way that you you prove
soundness of this uh this interactive
protocol is you do something called
rewinding so you say that if there is a
proverb that is sufficiently convincing
then I can uh it can run the prover uh
many many times on the last two messages
and basically
um record its answers to many many
different random questions
and I store its answers across many
questions in this uh in this extracted
proof
and by the end I either get some uh
convincing pcps and convincing proof
that is as convincing as the proofer
itself or or I observe some
inconsistency and finally the proofer is
breaking the underlying crypto
so already in the setting when you have
Quantum adversaries on the classical
Killian protocol
um recording the Proverbs answers is not
so straightforward because this uh
because this recording can eventually
disturb the proverb state right so if
you describe the proven State there's no
guarantee it's going to answer you on
your your further queries
um so this is something that uh we
addressed in recent work with Alessandra
keza myself Nick Spooner and Mark
um but there is really a way like even
when the proofer is quantum
um to get this this potentially
Disturbed uh previous state and to use
it to answer a later queries
um so a one slide recap of of what this
work is doing
um is that you're going to kind of run
the classical rewinding template where
you ask random questions to the approver
um but now when it answers you're gonna
you're gonna prepare its answers in
superposition
and uh instead of just like measuring it
right away you're going to measure if
the response is valid so you compute
this bit of whether the verifier would
accept the Proverbs answer
and only if that answer is valid do you
go ahead and measure the proofer's
response itself
the actual proof string
um and then after that all this all this
measurement has potentially Disturbed
the prover state
resulting in this new P Prime State and
uh the hard technical part of cmsz is
coming up with this repair procedure
where you show that actually there there
is some way to kind of repair the prover
so that it can answer you on on further
queries with the same success
probability as before
and really the the main idea of making
this work comes from you know combining
the statistical repair procedure with
the guarantees of the underlying crypto
where you have to say that you know as
long as the the scheme is instantiated
with a binding hash function a collapse
binding hash function then the second
step where you've measured the previous
response is undetectable
and then you can analyze this as if the
like step two didn't happen and that's
what really makes this repair work that
you can kind of bound the disturbance
approver and show that you can you can
repair them
so in our setting um this template
doesn't quite go through right we need
to extract a Quantum proof we're not
trying to extract the classical proof
string anymore so at the very least like
measuring the response isn't the right
thing to do right that's not going to be
enough to extract a Quantum proof
um but our definition kind of suggests
what the natural Quantum analog of this
is when you're trying to extract the
quantum proof and that's just to swap
out the the quantum response into some
external register
so um and the idea is to kind of uh run
the same with a template but every time
you you get an accepting answer swap out
the quantum message uh and the hope is
eventually you get some good Quantum PCP
at the end so when you get this
accepting response you run this swap uh
you record the answer and this extracted
proof register
um and then you you repair your wines
and the key point is that the swap
binding notion says that this step is
undetectable that that in the same way
that like measuring the the previous
response is undetectable in the post
Quantum setting uh swapping out the
message is undetectable when you're
aligning these Quantum groups these
Quantum protocols
um
so this approach nearly Works uh except
for what it's not basically said
um but I'll phrase the problem a little
differently
um which is that there's kind of this
tension between two different
requirements you need on the extractor
to make things work and one key
component of the of the way that the
cmsc procedure repairs the approver
state does it need the extractor to be
able to like run the prover and verify
the commitments are valid
but at the same time you need to argue
that you can analyze the the extractor
as if it's only doing these one-bit
measurements where these swaps don't
happen
and that requires you to to appeal to
the security of the of the underlying
commitments but like this whole talk
like you only have security if you give
away the commitment itself right you
can't have security if you're holding on
to both the C and D parts of the of the
overall committed state
so these these requirements are totally
incompatible for Quantum commitments
anyway like the first part to verify the
commitment you need the commitment and
to to argue any security you need the
extractor to not have the equipment and
so there's this very annoying tension
between these two things but really like
I think what's been happening all along
is that in the post Quantum setting we
could always get away with with not
worrying about the problem of verifying
the commitments if anyone can verify
openings
um and in the quantum setting that's
very far from true
um
and this issue shows up even when you're
just trying to extract classical
information as long as the commitment
scheme is quantum
um so uh
basically in the paper we show that
there is some way to get around this by
proving a slightly like proving that
swap binding generically implies a
slightly stronger definition that gives
you this limited access to the
underlying message basically giving you
like a verification Oracle
um maybe I'll end there and just say
that for uh future directions I think
there's a lot of open questions that
we've left
um one thing for instance is uh can we
build these distinct Quantum state
fitments from weaker assumptions such as
a pseudo-random States
um maybe uh could you remove Quantum
communication to what extent can you
remove Quantum communication from these
protocols and we definitely want like
simpler techniques
um for uh rewinding and extracting new
Quantum protocols
quantity
that would be the a strong motivation
for the second open faster
foreign
thing where um what you need is this
like short key encryption of long
messages and we actually have that
Frontier Essence uh in uh this apy paper
um and it doesn't work here uh as uh Sam
keeps playing out to me that uh because
this aqy procedure is not in unitary it
creates these junk States and there's
this problem of if you give the junk
states to the sender or the receiver if
they give it to the receiver it destroys
the same thing so you get the sender
destroys binding and it's uh it's really
unclear like how you do it
um
we need small key encryption that yes
questions offline
[Applause]
Finance session will be subscription
[Music]